ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN.
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE.
CALDERON CARILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DAILY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY.
LACKY LEVINE.
LIMON.
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS.
MAYES MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY YES THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER.
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
RIVER PATTY OSHA REDUCTION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THIS WAS INSPIRED BY AN ARTICLE
I READ.
ALL I REALLY NEED TO KNOW ABOUT
HOW TO LIVE LIFE.
I LEARNED IN KINDERGARTEN.
I FELT THAT THESE LIFE LESSONS
IN KINDNESS AND GOOD SENSE.
THAT WE ALSO LEARNED FROM OUR
MOMS AND DADS [inaudible]
PLAY FAIR.
DON'T HIT PEOPLE.
PUT THINGS BACK WHERE YOU FOUND
THEM.
CLEAN UP YOUR OWN MESS.
DON'T TAKE THINGS THAT AREN'T
YOURS.
SAY YOU'RE SORRY WHEN YOU HURT
SOMEBODY.
WASH YOUR HANDS BEFORE YOU EAT
[inaudible]
FLASH.
WARM COOKIES AND COLD MILK ARE
GOOD FOR YOU.
TAKE A NAP EVERY AFTERNOON.
WHEN YOU GO OUT IN THE WORLD?
WATCH OUT FOR TRAFFIC.
HOLD HANDS WHEN YOU CROSS THE
STREET AND STICK TOGETHER.
THINK WHAT A BETTER WORLD IT
WOULD BE FOR WE ALL THE WHOLE
WORLD.
HI COOKIES AND MILK IN THE
AFTERNOON AND TOOK A NAP.
AND WHEN WE GO OUT INTO THE
WORLD.
IN CROSSING THE BUSY
INTERSECTIONS OF LIFE.
ALWAYS REMEMBER THAT IS BEST TO
HOLD HANDS WITH AS MANY FRIENDS
AS WE POSSIBLY CAM. FOR THESE
WONDERFUL LIFE LESSONS OF
KINDNESS AND GOOD SENSE.
WE THANK OUR MOMS AND DADS.
IN KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS
EVERYWHERE.
NOW MOMENT ABSENT WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER GRAYSON.
PLEASE JOIN WITH ME I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES
[inaudible]
AND THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JUNE SIXTH
TWENTY NINETEEN RECENTLY MET AT
NINE AM AND WE'RE BACK UP OUR K.
HAN S. ISN'T SPEAKER PRO TEM OF
THIS ON THE PRESIDING CHEAP
COOKIE DOTSON WILSON AT THE DESK.
READING CLICK KATHLEEN AND LUIS
RESISTOR CALDERON MOVES AND MR
GIVES IN SECONDS THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION A REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY.
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JIM PATTERSON. FOR
ILLNESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER AL
MURATSUCHI.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN NAY TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OF OUR QUE HAN AND WEBER
TO HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OUT BY OUR CANS
GUESTS WILL BE SEATED AT HER
DESK ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBBER'S
GUESTS WILL BE IN THE AREA OF
THE MEMBERS DESK IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE JUNETEENTH RESOLUTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SPONSOR RUBIO
HOLDEN.
AND WEBER TO SPEAK ON AN
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY TODAY
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS
COMMITTEE.
SB TWENTY FIVE COVER YET -- FROM
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
TO THE LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
SB TWO SIXTY A WINNER FROM HUMAN
RE SERVICES COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE.
AND THAT'S ALL AGO.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT WILL SIXTY TWO A
THE PROBLEM NOTICE REQUIREMENT
TO ALLOW THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
TO HOLD AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ON WEDNESDAY WEDNESDAY JUNE
NINETEENTH AT ONE THIRTY PM IN
ROOM.
FORTY TWO OH TWO WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE THE RETENTION
MISTER FRAZIER MISSED FRAZIER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUESTS INFECTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME.
CHARLES NOT VICE CHAIR OF THE
STATE COUNCIL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND MICHAEL MCNULTY
FROM THE STATE COUNCIL OF
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I'M HONORED TO HAVE CHARLES
SHADOW WE ME FOR THE DAY WELCOME
CHARLES AND MICHAEL
.
MEMBERS IF I COULD HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION.
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH.
PLEASE WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY.
THE GRANADA HILLS CHARTER SCHOOL
ACADEMIC DECATHLON TEAM THERE
SEATED AND GALLERY LET'S PLEASE
WELCOME THEM TO THE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE THIS IS A C. R..
EIGHTY SIX THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE EIGHT C. R. EIGHTY
SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
JUNETEENTH.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU MAILED IT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS.
I RISE TODAY IN HONOR OF
JUNETEENTH NATIONAL FREEDOM DAY.
JUNE TENTH IS THE OLDEST AFRICAN
AMERICAN HOLIDAY IN THE UNITED
STATES.
AND WAS FIRST CELEBRATED IN.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE AFTER THE
WAR BETWEEN THE STATES BROKE OUT
OVER POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC
RAMIFICATIONS OF ENDING SLAVERY.
PRESIDENT LINCOLN'S SIGNED THE
EMANCIPATION PROCLAMATION.
WHICH FREED THE SLAVES IN THE
CONFEDERATE STATES.
THIS SIGNATURE TOOK PLACE ON
SEPTEMBER THE TWENTY SECOND.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO AND IT WAS
SIGNED WITH LINCOLN SAYING THAT
IT WOULD ONLY GOING AFFECT.
IF THE CONFEDERATE STATES.
DID NOT A COME BACK INTO THE
UNION.
WHAT'S DEMONSTRATED HE HAD
REALLY NO SERIOUS COMMITMENTS TO
THE ENDING OF SLAVERY.
BECAUSE THEY DID NOT COME BACK
TO THE UNION.
ON JANUARY FIRST EIGHTEEN SIXTY
THREE THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION WENT INTO EFFECT.
HOWEVER THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION DIDN'T FREE SLAVES
STATE SLAVES IN STATES THAT
WEREN'T IN REBELLION.
LIKE THE STATE OF TEXAS. THREE
YEARS AFTER THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION THERE WAS STILL
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
IN BONDAGE IN TEXAS.
ON JUNE.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE
WHEN THE UNION ARMY ROLLED INTO
GALVESTON THEY DISCOVERED THAT
THERE WERE MANY MANY SLAVES
STILL IN EXISTENCE IN TEXAS.
AND THEY WERE INFORMED AT THAT
TIME.
THAT THEY HAD BEEN FREE FOR
ALMOST THREE YEARS.
THEY BEGAN TO REJOICE.
AND A SPONTANEOUS CELEBRATION
TOOK PLACE.
A YEAR LATER.
THE FIRST ANNUAL JUNETEENTH
CELEBRATION TOOK PLACE IN
GALVESTON TEXAS.
JUNETEENTH IS A COMBINATION
BETWEEN THE WORD OF JUNE AND
NINETEEN THIS CELEBRATION WAS
THE PLAYER WAS BASICALLY
CELEBRATED THROUGHOUT THE SOUTH.
AND OVER THE YEARS MILLIONS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO IGRATED FROM
THE SOUTH BEGIN TO TAKE
JUNETEENTH WITH THEM.
THE CELEBRATION DECLINED IN THE
EARLY PART OF THE TWENTIETH
CENTURY.
BUT THERE WAS A RESURGENT OF IT
IN THE NINETEEN FIFTIES AND THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES.
TODAY JUNE TENTH IS CELEBRATED
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY WITH
SEVERAL TRADITIONS.
INCLUDING PARADES PICNICS
BARBECUES AND BIG RED SODA THAT
YOU WILL SEE IN THE LOUNGE.
THE SODA IS A STAPLE OF THE
JUNETEENTH GET TOGETHERS WHEN
COMMUNITIES JOIN TOGETHER TO
REFLECT ON THE HARDSHIP IN DORT
BY AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
BUT THE PERILOUS MIDDLE PASSAGE
TO THE BRUTALITY OF SLAVERY AND
JIM CROW TO THE STRUGGLES WE
FACE TODAY.
IT IS ALWAYS ALSO A TIME TO
CELEBRATE THE CONTRIBUTIONS AND
RICH CULTURAL TRADITIONS OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
A CULTURE SHAPE BY THE HISTORY
OF PERSEVERANCE STRENGTH AND
HOPE.
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES THE
GOVERNOR TO PROCLAIM THE THIRD
SATURDAY IN JUNE OF EACH YEAR TO
BE KNOWN AS JUNETEENTH.
FREEDOM NATIONAL DAY.
A DAY OF OBSERVANCE TO URGE ALL
CALIFORNIANS IN CELEBRATING THIS
DAY TO HONOR AND REFLECT ON THE
SIGNIFICANT ROLE THAT AFRICAN
AMERICANS HAVE PLAYED IN THE
HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND HOW AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN RICH SOCIETY THROUGH THEIR
STEADFAST COMMITMENT TO
PROMOTING FREEDOM BROTHERHOOD
AND EQUALITY.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I ASK
YOU TO JOIN ME IN PROCLAIMING
JUNE NINETEENTH.
JUNETEENTH NATIONAL FREEDOM DAY
AND I ASK FOR IT I VOTE FOR A C.
R..
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER MISS RUBIO.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM MISTER SPEAKER
IN MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF A C.
R..
EIGHTY SIX I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES FOR MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO FOR BRINGING
FORWARD THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
TODAY WE RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE
THE FREEDOM OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
SLAVES AT THE END OF THE CIVIL
WAR.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE CAN
COMMEMORATE THIS HISTORICAL
MILESTONE AND RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS WAS ONLY THE FIRST STEP.
TOWARDS EQUALITY AND JUSTICE.
THE SLEEVES OF GALVESTON TEXAS
HAD TO WAIT MORE THAN TWO YEARS
AFTER LINCOLN'S TO CREE TO
RECEIVE WORD THAT THEY WERE
FREED.
WE CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT MANY OF
THE SLAVES FELT.
ANXIOUSLY AWAITING FOR THE NEWS
OF THEIR FREEDOM.
DESPITE THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION AND RATIFICATION OF
THE THIRTEENTH AMENDMENT THE
STRUGGLE FOR EQUALITY FOR FORMER
SLAVES THEIR DESCENDANTS AND
AFRICAN AMERICANS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY HAS PROVEN LONG AND HARD.
WHILE WE CELEBRATE OUR HARD
FOUGHT VICTORIES WE MUST
RECOGNIZE THAT DISCRIMINATION
BUT DISCRIMINATION THAT STILL
EXISTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AS WE COMMEMORATE JUNETEENTH WE
MUST BE COGNIZANT OF THE
CONTINUED NEED TO COME TO COMBAT
RACISM.
HATE AND INTOLERANCE THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU HISTORY OF HIS RACE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF A C. R. EIGHTY SIX
RECOGNIZING JUNE NINETEENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN I WAS THE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOURTH
ANNIVERSARY OF JUNETEENTH.
AS HAS BEEN HIGHLIGHTED
JUNETEENTH IS A CELEBRATION OF
WHEN THE LAST SLAVES IN AMERICA
WERE FREED.
NEARLY TWO AND A HALF YEARS
AFTER THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION.
AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE A UNIQUE
AND OFTEN PAINFUL HISTORY IN
AMERICA AND THIS RESOLUTION IS
NOT ONLY A CELEBRATION.
BUT A RECOGNITION OF A RESPONSE
FROM A COMMUNITY ONE BUILT ON
STRENGTH RESILIENCE AND
FORTITUDE.
JUNETEENTH ALSO HIGHLIGHTS THE
FOLLOW THROUGH AND PERSISTENCE
NECESSARY TO ENACT JUSTICE.
THE NEED TO NOT ONLY PASSED JUST
LAWS BUT TO ENSURE.
THEY DO WHAT IS INTENDED AND
THAT THOSE IMPACTED BY THE LAWS
ARE MADE AWARE OF THE CHANGES.
THAT IS HOW TO TRULY MOVE
FORWARD IN WAYS THAT ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED.
THE LATINO CAUCUS STANDS IN
SOLIDARITY IN RECOGNITION OF
THIS CRITICAL ANNIVERSARY AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON A C. R..
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU MS RACE.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE RESOLUTION
DOCTOR WEBER YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES ARE RISING THIS
MORNING.
YOU KNOW WHEN I THINK OF
JUNETEENTH I'M OFTEN REMINDED OF
FREDERICK DOUGLASS THIS FOURTH
OF JULY ADDRESS.
FREDERICK DOUGLASS WAS INVITED
TO SPEAK BEFORE THE DAUGHTERS OF
THE REVOLUTION IN THE EIGHTEEN
FIFTIES.
AND THEY HAD EXPECTED HIM TO
TELL ALL THE WONDERS OF THE
FOURTH OF JULY.
THE WONDERS OF THIS NEW
CELEBRATE THE CELEBRATION OF
FREEDOM.
AND HE TALKED ABOUT IT AND THEN
HE SAID IF I BASICALLY FAIL TO
REMIND YOU WHO WE ARE.
IT WOULD BE A CRIME IT WOULD BE
A SHAME FOR THE NATION'S FOR ME
NOT TO TELL YOU WHAT THE FOURTH
OF JULY REALLY MEANS TO ME.
AND HE TALKED ABOUT HOW SLAVERY
HAD DENIED HIM ALL OF HIS
FREEDOM.
ALL OF HIS RIGHTS IN ALL OF HIS
HUMANITY.
AND HE SAID SO THEREFORE MY
SUBJECT TODAY WILL BE AMERICAN
SLAVERY AND NOT THE FOURTH OF
JULY.
AND HE SAID THAT IF I COULD GET
THE JERUSALEM.
THEN MAY MY RIGHT HAND FORGET
ARE CUTTING INTO YOUR TONGUE
CLEAVE TO THE ROOF OF MY MOUTH.
AS WE TALK ABOUT THIS
CELEBRATION JUNETEENTH.
WE LOOK AT HOW FAR WE'VE COME.
AND YET HOW FAR WE HAVE NOT COME
AS A NATION.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT AFRICAN
AMERICANS HAVE STRUGGLED IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND THE SAD THING IS EVEN IN
THIS TIME FRAME MANY OF US FEEL
AS IF WE ARE OUTSIDE LOOKING IN
THE WINDOW OF FREEDOM.
THAT WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
PICTURE AND THE CELEBRATION
THAT'S THEIR AND IT'S VERY
PAINFUL TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
I REMEMBER ONCE AS A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER I TENDED TO BE A
CELEBRATION ON BEHALF OF THE
LINCOLN AND WASHINGTON
CELEBRATION OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
AND I SAW IN THE FACE OF SO MANY
WHO LOVE THIS COUNTRY.
THE TEARS THAT THEY SHARE AT
THAT MOMENT.
AND I BIG REALIZE THAT I FELT
LIKE AROUND BEEN IT THE
HISTORIAN.
WHO SAID WHEN HE WENT TO THE
FREEDOM OF GHANA?
AND HE SAW WHEN THEY HAD GOTTEN
THEIR FREEDOM IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES.
HE SAW THE TEARS ON THEIR FACE
AND THE AND THE WONDER THAT THEY
HAD IN THEIR HEARTS OF OF ONCE
AGAIN GETTING FREEDOM AGAIN.
AND HE SAID HE FELT LIKE AN
OUTSIDER AGAIN.
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T HAVE THE SAME
PASSION AND THE SAME LOVE NO
MATTER HOW HARD HE TRIED.
AND I THINK ABOUT THAT IN
RELATIONSHIP TO US AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THIS COUNTRY.
WAS STILL TRYING TO TELL THEIR
STORY ABOUT FREEDOM.
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW PAINFUL
SLAVERY WAS AND WHAT IT TOOK
FROM US AS A PEOPLE.
AS WE CONTINUE TO TRY TO MAKE A
LIFE IN THIS NATION.
A PAINFUL SITUATION THAT IS
THERE.
IF YOU EVER GET A CHANCE TO BE
SURE TO LOOK AT THE SMITHSONIAN
AND LISTEN TO THE TAPES OF THE
SMITHSONIAN THAT TALKED ABOUT.
IN NINETEEN THIRTY WHEN THEY
WENT AND THEY INTERVIEWED FORMER
SLAVES.
AND YOU HEAR THEIR VOICES.
AND YOU HEAR WHAT HAPPENED TO
THEM AFTER THEY WERE FREED.
HOW THEY HAD ABSOLUTELY NOTHING?
NOT EVEN A GOOD CLOSE NOT SHOES
ONLY NOT A PENNY IN THEIR POCKET.
AND HOW THEY HAD TO STRUGGLE SO
HARD JUST TO MAKE AN EXISTENCE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND YET AT THE SAME TIME SOMEONE
SAID TO THE ONE PERSON HE SAID.
BEEN REALLY HE SAID YOU WOULD
HAVE PREFERRED TO REMAIN IN
SLAVERY BECAUSE AT LEAST YOU
KNEW WHO OWNS YOU AND WHERE YOU
WOULD STAY IN WHERE YOU WOULD
SLEEP IN WHERE YOU WOULD EAT.
AND THIS MAN SAID AND I REMEMBER
THIS SO CLEARLY BECAUSE IT WAS
AT THE END OF THE FILM HE SAID
IF I THOUGHT. FOR ONE MOMENT.
THAT SLAVERY WOULD COME BACK
TOMORROW.
I WOULD KILL MYSELF TODAY.
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WE HAVE TO
STRUGGLE REALLY HARD IN THIS
COUNTRY TO UNDERSTAND THE PAIN
THAT IS THERE.
BUT IN THE MIDST OF ALL OF THAT
WE HAVE TO ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
JOY THAT WE HAVE.
IN THIS COUNTRY IS AFRICAN
AMERICANS.
AS WE STRUGGLE CONSTANTLY WITH
AN APPLE OPTIMISTIC VIEW POINT.
THAT THE WORLD WILL BE BETTER
TOMORROW THAT EVERYTHING WE DO
WILL CHANGE THE WORLD THAT WE
LIVE IN.
AND THAT WE HAVE THE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY THE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE THE GENERATION
THAT FINALLY OVERCOMES SOME OF
THE MONSTERS OF OUR OUR
FOREFATHERS.
THEN WE CAN PIERCE THOSE PARTS.
THAT WE CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
I REMEMBER I WROTE AN ARTICLE
AFTER OBAMA WON IN IOWA.
AND I SAW WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN
MY CLASSROOM.
AND I WROTE AN ARTICLE FOR A
MAGAZINE IN OCEANSIDE THIS SAYS
PLANTING TREES WITHOUT SEEING
THE FOREST.
BECAUSE I HAD BEEN WORKING SO
HARD TO CHANGE THE HEARTS AND
MINDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE IN MY
CLASSES AND WHEN I LOOKED UP
THERE WAS A FOREST OF GOOD WILL.
AND SO WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE EACH AND EVERY DAY.
AND SO AS A RESULT OF THAT THERE
IS JOY IN AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES.
YOU WILL HEAR SOME OF THE DAY
WHEN YOU HEAR A SONG THAT'S
GOING TO BE SOME.
YOU WILL UNDERSTAND THAT DESPITE
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED THERE IS NO BITTERNESS.
WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT NOT BEING
BITTER BUT BEING BETTER.
AND I WANT TO CHALLENGE YOU ALSO
TODAY TO PUT PUT WITHIN YOURSELF
TO UNDERSTAND THE PAIN THAT HAS
EXISTED IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AND DESPITE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE EVERY DAY TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A C. R. EIGHTY SIX AND
THAT THE FIRST ROLE WAS OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
MEMBERS.
THE CLERK LEVEL THE ROLE.
IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON A C.
R..
EIGHTY SIX THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
FOUR CO AUTHORS ADDED ON THE
RESOLUTION AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
DOCTOR WEBER AND THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS TODAY
ARE TREATING US TO A SPECIAL
PERFORMANCE.
PLEASE WELCOME THE MLK
CELEBRATION CHOIR.
UNDER THE DIRECTION OF DR TO
QUITE PORTER THE CHOIR WILL SING
THE GOSPEL SPIRITUAL. OH HAPPY
DAY.
DOCTOR PORTER.
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THE
WHOLE [inaudible]
IS [inaudible]
A
AS LONG.
BUT ONE OF THE FOUR MEN'S DOCTOR
WEBER IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS ARE
ALSO INVITING MEMBERS TO SAMPLE.
BIG RED SODA BEVERAGE
TRADITIONALLY SIR FOR JUNETEENTH
AND THAT IS IN THE LOUNGE IS
THAT RIGHT DOCTOR WEBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES.
OUR PERFORMANCE
.
MEMBERS WE DO HAVE ADDITIONAL
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US.
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MR HOLDEN I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
GUESTS WITH US.
IN THE GALLERY TODAY I DO THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER -- EVERY YEAR
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
IDENTIFY YOUNG PEOPLE IN OUR
DISTRICT.
WHO ARE A SPIRE TO BE IN PUBLIC
SERVICE AND THEN WE CREATE A
PROGRAM OVER A PERIOD OF SIX
MONTHS THE CULMINATES HERE?
IN SACRAMENTO WHERE THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COME HERE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND SEE.
WHAT THEY'VE LEARNED?
BEING PUT IN ACTION AND SO TODAY
I HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
RECOGNIZING -- WE HAVE ABOUT A
FOURTEEN TO SIXTEEN YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO ARE LEGISLATORS OF THE YEAR --
ARE YOUNG LEGISLATORS I SHOULD
SAY AND THEY'RE HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH THIS TODAY SO LET'S
OR GIVE THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
AND WELCOME THEM TO SACRAMENTO.
MAKE THE CLOSER.
TO TWENTY MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SAMPLE FOR SIXTY NINE WITH THE
MOMENTS AND TWO THIRTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MISTER CALDERON FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE
TO WITHDRAW THE FOLLOWING BUDGET
TRAILER BILLS FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING TO TAKE A
TICKET TO TAKE THEM UP FOR THIRD
READING WITHOUT REFERENCE THE
FILE THOSE BILLS ARE SB SEVENTY
SIX SB.
SEVENTY SEVEN SB EIGHTY TWO SB
EIGHTY THREE SB EIGHTY FOUR SB
EIGHTY FIVE SB EIGHTY SEVEN SB
NINETY TWO SB.
NINETY THREE SB NINETY FOUR SB
NINETY FIVE SB NINETY SIX SB ONE
OF THREE SB.
ONE OH FIVE YEAH MISTER FLOOR
FOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I HAVE THE FULL
UNANIMOUS CONSENT HOUSE FOR ROLL
CALL VOTE.
MR FLORA IS WITHHOLDING MEMBERS
THIS IS A RULE SUSPENSION
PROCEDURAL VOTE MISTER CALDERON
MOVES.
AND MR BONTA SECONDS.
THAT THE RULES BE SUSPENDED
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE TO MR BOUGHT THEM PARMI
MISTER FLORES ASKING FOR NO
VOCAL CLUB IN THE ROLE.
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE WHICH
CALDERON TRANSFERRED AYE.
MR FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO.
ON THE ROLE SUSPENSION.
THIS TAKES FORTY AND A SEVENTY
NINE MEMBER HOUSE [inaudible]
YEAH.
MEMBERS THIS IS PROCEDURAL.
MISTER CALDERON ASKING FOR I AM
MISTER FLORA NO [inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS TWELVE THE RULES
[inaudible]
ARE SUSPENDED
.
MEMBER SIGN RECONSIDERATION
ITEMS NUMBER THREE AND FOUR ARE
TO BE CONTINUED ON THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE.
FILE ITEMS FIVE THROUGH NINE
PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN ACR FIFTY SEVEN BY.
MISTER BREAUX CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BRO AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE
AMERICAN LEGION.
SHARON EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE RESENT ACR FIFTY SEVEN
RECOGNIZING THE ONE HUNDREDTH
ANNIVERSARY THE AMERICAN LEGION
AND ITS SERVICE TO THE UNITED
STATES.
CONGRESSIONALLY CHARTERED IN
NINETEEN NINETEEN THE AMERICAN
LEGION HAS BEEN A PATRIOTIC
VETERANS ORGANIZATION FOCUSING
ON SERVICE TO VETERANS SERVICE
MEMBERS AND COMMUNITIES.
WITH NEARLY TWO MILLION MEMBERS
THE AMERICAN LEGION'S PRESENT IN
ALL FIFTY STATES AS WELL AS
FRANCE MEXICO THE PHILIPPINES
AND PORTER RICO.
THE APPROXIMATELY THIRTEEN
THOUSAND POSTS WORLDWIDE IN
CALIFORNIA WERE HOME TO A
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS AND
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
AMERICAN LEGION POST INCLUDING
MY ONLY GOOD AND THE GAL POST.
TO EIGHTY ONE DELETION HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN CREATION OF
NUMBER MAJOR INSTITUTIONS IN
AMERICAN SOCIETY.
INCLUDING FORMATIONS THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
CREATION OF THE US FLAG CODE AND
PASSAGE ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THE GI BILL OF RIGHTS IN.
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR ANYWAY THE
AMERICAN LEGION POST CONTRIBUTE
TO MORE THAN THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION HOURS OF VOLUNTEER
SERVICE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS MORE THAN A HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND VA BENEFITS
CLAIMS IN CASES AND THEY WARD
MORE THAN FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN COLLEGE SCHOLARSHIPS.
THE LEGION IS A VITAL
ORGANIZATION THAT BRINGS
VETERANS TOGETHER HELPS CONNECT
VETERANS TO THEIR BENEFITS AND
FOCUSES ON GIVING BACK TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
MEMBERS IT'S IMPORTANT AT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HONOR THE
AMERICAN LEGION FOR ITS ONE
HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY.
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR THE
FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CALL
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER BROWN SEEING NO
MEMBER SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE RESOLUTION MR ROSE ASSN OF
THE FIRST ROLL THE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON A C. R..
FIFTY SEVEN THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY
TWO CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MEAN TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE WE ARE GOING TO BE TAKING
UP SB. ONE OH THREE SB
[inaudible]
ONE OH THREE CORPORATION.
SENATE BILL ONE OH THREE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT MAKING A
PROBATION THERE FOR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET.
MR TANG EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS
THE FIRST OF MANY TRAILER BILL
TODAY SB.
ONE OH THREE RATIFIES MO YOU FOR
BARGAINING UNIT SIX WHICH IS THE
CORRECTIONS ALL DIVISION.
THEM A USE FOR ONE YEAR IT'S
IMPACTING 270-006-0090.
FOUR EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYEES
WILL RECEIVE A 3% PAY INCREASE --
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON SB.
ONE OH THREE THANKS FOR STAYING
MISTER OF ARNOLDI MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE OH
THREE THE COMPENSATION INCREASES
PROVIDED THE SO WHEN YOU ARE
MODEST THERE IN LINE WITH
INFLATION.
AND THEREFORE SUPPORTABLE
HOWEVER I HAVE TO EXPRESS MY
FRUSTRATION THAT FOR SEVERAL
YEARS NOW THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
NOT PROVIDED THE COMPENSATION
ROUTE -- SURVEYS THAT ARE
REQUIRED BY STATE LAW TO
PROVIDED TO US THE LEGISLATURE
IN ORDER TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION ON THIS.
THE PART IN A FINANCE TELLS US
THAT THE REASON WHY THE SURVEYS
HAVE NOT BEEN RETURNED IS THAT
THEY'RE UNABLE TO AGREE WITH THE
BARGAINING UNIT ON METHODOLOGY
BUT I SAY IF THAT'S THE CASE.
PLEASE GIVE US TWO ONE THAT THE
BARGAINING UNIT AGREES WITH ONE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION AGREES
WITH WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO MAKE
THIS DECISION IN A VACUUM SO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE US.
NEXT YEAR TO HOLD THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FEET TO THE
FIRE DEMAND THAT THAT SURVEY BE
PROVIDED TO US BUT FOR NOW I
ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS ROBIN OAKLEY SEEN
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
ON THE TRAILER BILL.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF WHO IS OUR ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
SEVENTY THREE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE.
MEMBERS THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE SB
[inaudible]
ONE OH FIVE CLOCK RATE.
SENATE BILL ONE OH FIVE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY TO
CORRECTIONS MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET.
MR TING YOU MAY GET OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB ONE
OH FIVE INCREASES THE LEASE
REVENUE BOND FUNDING. FOR THE
CORRECTIONS DEPARTMENT'S HEALTH
CARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS.
BY ALMOST FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
BRINGING THE TOTAL FOR THESE
PROJECTS TO ONE POINT ONE FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS.
THESE PROJECTS ARE ALL MANDATED.
BY OUR RECEIVER AND ARE REQUIRED.
UNDER THE RECEIVER TO BE DONE
WITHOUT RESPECT FAST PRIVATE.
THINGS TING MISTER OF ADULTERY
THANK YOU RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE OH FIVE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST AGREES THAT THIS REQUEST
IS JUSTIFIED ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK MISTER OF NINETY AND WITH
THAT.
CLARK WELL.
OVER THERE ALL.
OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
OR WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL. TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
IS SB.
SEVENTY SIX CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY SIX BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY TO EDUCATION
FINANCE MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET.
MR TAG THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SB SEVENTY SIX IS THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT CERT TRAILER BILL.
THOUGHT OF THE COMPANION TO OUR
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL THE BILL
MAKES CHANGES TO PROP -- NINETY
EIGHT TO THE PROPER IDEAS
CERTIFICATION PROCESS BY
ELIMINATED THE COST ALLOCATION
SCHEDULE CREATED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET.
IT ALSO PROHIBITS THE STATE FROM
MAKING DOWNWARD ADJUSTMENTS TO
THE PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
LEVEL ONCE A FISCAL YEAR IS OVER.
THE BILL PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY TWO MILLION IMPROPER
NINETY EIGHT SETTLE UP FUNDING.
TO REDUCE THE OUTSTANDING PROP
NINETY FUNDING -- TO SCHOOLS
FROM PRIOR YEARS.
I IT ALSO INCLUDES A COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
I WHICH IS WHICH WILL BE
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED
WITHOUT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FIVE THANK WHICH TAKE EM MISTRAL
SEA.
THIS IS BIGGER RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVENTY SIX THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING METHODOLOGY FOR K.
TWELVE EDUCATION FOR THE NEXT
YEAR.
AS YOU KNOW PROP I NEED IS A
VERY COMPLEX FORMULA THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO ESTABLISH A BASELINE
FOR EDUCATION FUNDING.
ONCE THIS FUNDING IS PHASED IN
WILL BE FUNDING K. TWELVE
EDUCATION AT A MODEST INCREASE
FROM LAST YEAR BY MODEST I MEAN
IN LINE WITH INFLATION THAT'LL
BRING PER STUDENT SPENDING UP TO
A LITTLE BIT OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER STUDENT.
BUT TO PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE
THAT WILL STILL MAKE US FORTY
FIRST IN THE NATION OUT OF FIFTY
STATES WHEN THE COST OF LIVING
IS FACTORED IN AND GIVEN THAT
STATISTICALLY IT IS NO SURPRISE.
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE LOWEST TEACHER TO STUDENT
RATIO OF ALL FIFTY STATES SO
ALTHOUGH THIS MOVE THE BALL IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION I REGION I
VOTE FOR NOW.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE THIS BODY TO
CONSIDER FUNDING EDUCATION AT A
GREATER LEVEL IN THE FUTURE PROP
NINETY EIGHT WAS INTENDED BY THE
VOTERS TO BE -- A FLOOR ON
EDUCATION FUNDING NOT A CEILING
AND WE CONTINUE TO TREAT IT AS A
CEILING BUT FOR NOW ARJUNA VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OVER NOTING
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM CARPOOL OPEN THE
ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
STARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT.
AYE AYES.
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE.
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
THIS IS SB.
SEVENTY SEVEN CORPORATION
SENATE BILL SEVENTY SEVEN BY THE
COMMITTEE AND BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET.
MR TING.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB
SEVENTY SEVEN IS OUR HIGHER ED
TRAILER BILL.
HAS MANY PROGRAMS TO HELP
FAMILIES GO TO COLLEGE.
THE FIRST IS OUR NEW COLLEGE
SAVINGS PROGRAM.
WHICH IS PRIMARILY GEARED TOWARD
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS.
HALF THE PROCEEDS WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED LOCAL EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND THE OTHER HALF WILL
BE TO DEVELOPING NEW PROGRAM
THROUGH OUR STATE SCHOLAR SHARE
BOARD.
THE BILL ALSO SUPPORTS MAJOR
INVESTMENTS IN FINANCIAL AID.
IT INCREASES THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS BY MORE
THAN FIFTEEN THOUSAND PROVIDE.
PROVIDE A SECOND YOU'RE FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TUITION ALSO
SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE EXTRA FUNDING TO LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WITH DEPENDENT
CHILDREN.
INCREASE A STATE WORK STUDY
PROGRAM FOR DREAM ASK STUDENTS
WHO DO NOT QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL
WORK STUDY JOBS WITHOUT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
AB ON SB.
SEVENTY SEVEN THANK IMAGE TING
MISERABLY MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN OPPOSITION SB SEVENTY SEVEN
THIS BILL IS WELL INTENTIONED
BUT UNFORTUNATELY FAILS TO SOLVE
A LOT OF THE PROBLEMS THAT ARE
FACING HIGHER EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT -- PROPOSES A SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE FOR EXAMPLE TO
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS BUT AT
THE SAME TIME INCREASES
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR CAL
GRANT TO THE POINT WHERE THIS
PROGRAM WILL BE JUST AS IMPACTED
AS IT WAS BEFORE -- IT ALSO
EXTENDS FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SUPPOSEDLY FOR ALL.
CALIFORNIANS THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE
PROGRAM BUT UNFORTUNATELY NONE
OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN MY
DISTRICT QUALIFY THAT BECAUSE OF
THE STRINGS ATTACHED IF WE'RE
GOING TO EXTEND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IT SHOULD BE. TO FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE THERE FOR CHEN
A VOTE.
SEE NO ADDITIONALDISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS SMOKE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHAT IS ART ABOUT [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY THREE KNOWS EIGHT THAT
MEASURE PASSES AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
IS SB [inaudible] EIGHTY TWO
CALGARY.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY TWO BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
GOVERNMENT MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET.
MR TAKE YOU MAY GET OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB
EIGHTY TWO IS THE FIRST OF TWO
GENERAL GOVERNMENT TRAILER BILLS --
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THE OFFICE
OF DIGITAL INFORMATION
INNOVATION.
THEY AUTHORIZES THE ADJUSTMENT
OF RENEWAL FEES FOR VARIOUS
LICENSEES UNDER THE ALCOHOL
BEVERAGE CONTROL ACT IT ALSO
ELIMINATES A TO SUB ACCOUNTS IN
THE SAFETY NET RESERVE FUND.
THAT ALLOWS THE FUND TO BE
UTILIZED TO MAINTAIN EXISTING
PROGRAM BENEFITS AND SERVICES
FOR MEDI CAL AND CAL WORKS
PROGRAMS DURING ECONOMIC
DOWNTURNS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAMBERS ROBERT
ALTON MISTER SPEAKER THIS BILL
CONTAINS MANY -- SUPPORTABLE
PROVISIONS BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT
ALSO CONTAINS A VERY TROUBLING
ONES -- IT ALLOWS THE COUNTY OF
CINEMA TO DISPOSE OF THE SONOMA
REGIONAL CENTER THAT CENTER WAS
CREATED FOR THE PURPOSE OF
SERVING THE NEEDS OF THIS
ABILITY COMMUNITY WHEN WE ASK
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
HOW THE PROCEEDS FROM THEIR
DISPOSAL WOULD BE SPENT THE DEAL
HAVE SAID THAT THEY WOULD BE
DEPOSITED BACK IN THE GENERAL
FUND?
COLLEGE I THINK THAT IS
EXTREMELY INAPPROPRIATE THOSE
FUNDS SHOULD BE USED FOR HEALTH
SERVICES AND FOR HOUSING FOR THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY NOT
DEPOSITED BACK IN THE GENERAL
FUND ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OF NOT THE SAME
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE.
ON THE TRAILER BILL.
CLARK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS OF WE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ART ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT EYES FIFTY
NINE IT KNOWS.
ELEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL. TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
THIS IS SB [inaudible]
EIGHTY THREE CLICK RATE.
SEVERAL EIGHTY THREE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE%
BUDGET.
MISTER TECH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB
EIGHTY THREE IS OUR LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT TRAILER BILL.
THE BILL EXTENDS THE RELATION OF
PAID FAMILY LEAVE BENEFITS FROM
SIX WEEKS TO EIGHT WEEKS.
BEGINNING JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY IT REDUCES THE RESERVE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE DISABILITY
INSURANCE FUND FROM 45%. 230%
INCLUDES INTENT LANGUAGE TO
CONVENE A TASK FORCE TO DEVELOP
A PROPOSAL BY NOVEMBER. TWENTY
NINETEEN TO EXTEND THE DURATION
OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE BENEFITS TO
SIX MONTHS BY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WITH THE GOAL
OF INCREASING THE WAGE
REPLACEMENT RATE 290%.
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS A ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO CREATE OUR
REGION EDUCATION GRANT PROGRAM
FOR DOMESTIC WORKERS.
IT ALSO ELIMINATES PAYROLL
DEFERRALS FOR EMPLOYEES AND
MAKES OTHER CHANGES RELATED TO
LABOR THE POINT.
WITH THAT WE RESPECT FOR US
RIGHT NOW.
NAME IS CHIANG MISTER OF AN
OLDIE MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHTY THREE
THIS TRAILER BILL INCREASES THE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM FROM
SIX WEEKS TO EIGHT WEEKS WE HAVE
A ROBUST DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS
BILL IN THE BUDGET CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE.
AND EVERYONE WANTS TO PRETEND
THAT THIS COMES WITHOUT A COST
BUT THE COST INVOLVED IS
SUBSTANTIAL THE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE PROGRAM IS PART OF THE
STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
PROGRAM AN STI IS FUNDED.
THROUGH A PAYROLL TAX DEDUCTION
ON THE PAYCHECK OF EVERY WORKER
IN CALIFORNIA THE AMOUNT OF THAT
PAYROLL DEDUCTION IS SET EVERY
YEAR DEPENDING ON THE NUMBER OF
CLAIMS FROM THE PREVIOUS YEAR
AGAINST THE PROGRAM AND THE
BALANCE ON THE PROGRAM FUND.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST TELLS US
THAT INCREASING PAID FAMILY
LEAVE FROM SIX WEEKS TO EIGHT
WEEKS WILL CAUSE A 10% GREATER
SUBSCRIPTION RATE FOR THE NEXT
YEAR THAN THE PREVIOUS YEAR
WHICH MEANS I PAYROLL TAX.
WILL HAVE TO GO UP 10% OR HIGHER
THAN IT WOULD HAVE BEEN WITHOUT
IT.
IF YOU DO THE MATH THAT WILL
RESULT IN ABOUT SIXTY DOLLARS
LESS IN THE POCKET OF EVERY
SINGLE CALIFORNIA WORKER IN THE
NEXT YEAR.
NOW THAT MIGHT NOT BE A LOT OF
MONEY TO YOU OR TO ME BUT FOR
SOME OF OUR CONSTITUENTS THAT
SIXTY DOLLARS A YEAR IS A LOT OF
MONEY -- AND I DID IT SO IT'S
NOT WITHOUT A COST EVEN MORE
TROUBLING IS THE TASK FORCE THAT
THIS TRAILER BILL ESTABLISHES TO
TRY AN INCREASE THE PAID FAMILY
FROM EIGHT WEEKS TO SIX MONTHS
WHICH WOULD BE MANY TIMES MORE
EXPENSIVE.
MY ORIGINAL VOTE.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
SIXTY KNOWS ELEVEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES IN WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE SB.
EIGHTY FOUR COVERAGE.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY FOUR BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND EXPLAIN TO THE FLOW
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR IT MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL REALLY TO THE
BUDGET.
MR TANK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB
EIGHTY FOUR ALLOWS FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
REPLACEMENT SYSTEM FOR THE
STATE'S ONLINE.
ELECTRIC FILING SYSTEM FOR
CAMPAIGN STATEMENTS ALSO KNOWN
AS CAL ACCESS TO BE DELAYED FROM
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST. TWENTY
TWENTY TO FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE DELAY WILL ENSURE THE
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION DOES NOT
THIS ROB.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
SYSTEM.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
A MATCHING MEASURABLE THING.
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHTY FOR THIS BILL WILL
AID IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF CAL
ACCESS WHICH IS THE STATE'S
ONLINE CAMPAIGN DISCLOSURE
SYSTEM ARJUN AYE VOTE.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
THESE ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLLER TODD ABOUT I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL.
TO THE SENATE WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE THIS IS SB.
EIGHTY FIVE COVERAGE.
SAMPLE EIGHTY FIVE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET [inaudible]
MISTER TECH.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER SENATE BILL
EIGHTY FIVE ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS REVOLVING FUND IT MAKES
A NUMBEROF CHANGES TO DEFINE
AND CLARIFY THE MISSION
RESPONSIBILITY.
OF CALIFORNIANS DIVISION OF FIRE
AND LIFE SAFETY.
IT EXTENDS THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND BY TEN YEARS.
IT ALSO DEFINES LOW ACCESS AREAS
REQUIRES A GRANT RECIPIENT OF
THE HEALTHY STORES REFRIGERATION
AND GRANT PROGRAM.
BE LOCATED IN A LOW INCOME AREA
OR A LOW ACCESS AREA.
REMOVE THE CAP ON THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF FUNDS THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD MAY COLLECT FOR
CERTIFICATION OF THEY PROTECT
WATER RESOURCES.
AND WILDLIFE HABITAT WILL
ADDRESSING FIRE BEHAVIOR AND
PUBLIC SAFETY WITHOUT A RESPECT
FOR US RIGHT.
THEY WISH TO MUCH TROUBLE THE
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION SB FIVE AMONG ITS
OTHER PROVISIONS OF THIS TRAILER
BILL WOULD COMPLETELY REMOVE THE
CAP.
ON A LARGE CATEGORIES OF FEES
CHARGED BY THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD THIS WOULD HAVE
THE EFFECT OF ALLOWING THE BOARD
TO RAISE THOSE FEES WITH NO
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
IN THE FUTURE AND REMOVING OF
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT FROM THOSE --
THE SETTING OF THOSE FEES IS
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC GIVEN
THE TROUBLED RELATIONSHIPS THAT
THEY ARE BE HAS HAD WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN RECENT YEARS I
ORIGINAL VOTE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TALLY ABOUT EYES.
FIFTY KNOWS.
SIXTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES IN
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL. TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
THIS IS SB [inaudible] EIGHTY
SEVEN COVERAGE.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG.
MR FONG ON THE AMENDMENTS.
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
OFFER AMENDMENTS TO DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AN UPCOMING
TAX INCREASE A GAS TAX INCREASE
HEADED OUR WAY ON JULY FIRST
CALIFORNIA VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE HIGH COST OF GASOLINE.
IN THIS AMENDMENT WOULD PROVIDE
THEM WITH MUCH YOU TO RELIEF
WITH A TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS
SURPLUS THERE'S NO REASON WE
CANNOT PROVIDE TEMPORARY RELIEF
TO CALIFORNIA MOTORISTS RIGHT
NOW I ASKED WE AYE VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON FOR PURPOSE --
MOVED TO LAY THE IMMINENCE ON
THE TABLE MISTER CALDERON MOVES
LADY MAN IT'S ON THE TABLE.
THE SECOND BY MISTER BONTA
[inaudible]
EVEREST.
WHICH GALLAGHER SAGE POINT OF
ORDER NOT THE PROPER MOTION IS
NOT TO LAY ON THE TABLE THE
PROPER MOTION WOULD BE TO
POSTPONE DEFINITELY IT REQUIRES
A TWO THIRDS VOTE -- TO DO THAT
LAYING ON THE TABLE IS NOT
PERMITTED UNDER THE TOPICAL
RULES. FOR THE ASSEMBLY ROLES
THIS MOTION IS IN ORDER WE DO
HAVE A A MOTION AND A SECOND BY
MISTER BONTA MEMBERS IS A
PROCEDURALVOTE TO LADY
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
AND MR FONG IS ASKING FOR A NO
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
ON LAINEY MEMBERS ON THE TABLE
MR FUNG'S ASKING FOR NOW.
THIS IS A MAJORITY PRESENT AND
VOTING THRESHOLD.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW IT ABOUT ICE
FORTY NINE KNOWS SEVENTEEN THE
MEMBERS ARE LAID ON THE TABLE.
NOW TO THE BILLING CHIEF.
CLOCK RATE.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY SEVEN BUT THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE
TRANSPORTATION MAKING IN
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER TECH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB
EIGHTY SEVEN IS OUR
TRANSPORTATION BUDGET TRAILER
BILL IT REPAYS ALL OUTSTANDING
GENERAL FUND TRANSPORTATION
LOANS IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY THIS INCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
MILLION FROM THE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION RELIEF FUND.
IN APPROXIMATELY EIGHT HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX MILLION IN LOANS WAIT
FEES.
IT ALSO PROVIDES CONFIDENTIALITY
PROTECTIONS TO INDIVIDUALS TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION'S INDEPENDENT
OFFICE OF AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS.
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED BY SB ONE
IT ALSO ESTABLISHES A
COMPETITIVE GRANT.
PROGRAM FOR SHORTLINE RAILROAD
PROJECTS USING UP TO SEVEN POINT
TWO MILLION FROM THE TRADE
CORRIDOR IMPROVEMENTS.
NAME IS CHIANG MISTER OVER.
NINETY MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHTY SEVEN
COLLEGE THE MOST TROUBLING
ASPECT OF THIS TRAILER BILL IN
MY OPINION IS RELATED TO VEHICLE
WEIGHT FEES AS YOU KNOW VEHICLE
WEIGHT FEES.
ARE CHARGED TO OPERATORS OF
LARGE COMMERCIAL VEHICLES TO
MITIGATE THE DAMAGE OF THOSE
VEHICLES DUE TO THE STATE'S
INFRASTRUCTURE.
STICK HEARD STATE LAW ALLOWS
THOSE WAIT FEES TO BE
TRANSFERRED TO THE GENERAL FUND
TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO REPAY TRANSPORTATION
RELATED BOND AT THAT'S AN ACTUAL
THAT I'VE OPPOSED IN THE PAST
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE.
HOWEVER THIS TRAILER BILL MAKES
THE FART SITUATION FAR WORSE IT
ALLOWS THOSE REVENUES TO BE
TRANSFERRED TO THE GENERAL FUND
WITHOUT LIMIT ESSENTIALLY AND BE
USED FOR THE REPAYMENT OF FUTURE.
TRANSPORTATION BOND LEAD IN ANY
YEAR SO IN OTHER WORDS ALL OF
THOSE VEHICLE WEIGHT FEES CAN BE
DIVERTED TO THE GENERAL FUND
INSTEAD OF BEING LEFT IN THE
HIGHWAY ACCOUNT.
COLLEAGUES WHEN THE OPERATORS OF
THESE COMMERCIAL VEHICLES PAY
THESE FEES IT IS WITH THE
EXPECTATION THAT THEY BE USED.
TO MAINTAIN OF THE STATE'S
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS IS VERY
INAPPROPRIATE AND I REGIONAL
VOTE.
MR FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKE MEMBERS
REMEMBER. THREE YEARS AGO WHEN
WE SAID THAT THERE WAS A FIFTY
NINE BILLION DOLLAR BACKLOG.
IN DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ON OUR
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAYS
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE OVER
FIFTY THOUSAND MILES OF HIGHWAY.
AND THIRTEEN THOUSAND BRIDGES TO
MAINTAIN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS OF LAST YEAR THE BE -- WE DID
NOT IMPLEMENT THE SWAP AND WE
LOST SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
LAST YEAR IN THAT TRANSACTION.
I URGE NO VOTE.
THINGS FRAZIER SAY NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS OF WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE.
FIFTY FOUR NO.
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
IS SB.
NINETY TWO OPERATE.
SENATE BILL NINETY TWO BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE TAXATION
MAKING APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER KING I THINK IT WAS
SPEAKER SB NINETY TWOS ARE
REVENUES OF TRAILER BILL.
THE BILL EXEMPTS DIAPERS AND
TAMPONS FROM SALES TAX FROM.
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
TWO THE BILL LIMITS CD TSA'S
ABILITY TO DEMAND PAYMENT OF
TAXES DUE FROM SPECIFIC
RETAILERS.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE
OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS TO CREATE
A PROCESS.
UNDER WHICH A PERSON FILING
APPEAL MAY CHOOSE TO APPEAR
BEFORE ONE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE RATHER THAN A PANEL UNDER
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
THE THE STRUGGLE.
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINETY TWO THIS BILL WOULD
EXEMPT FEMININE HYGIENE PRODUCTS
AND DIAPERS FROM SALES TAX BUT
ONLY FOR A PERIOD OF TWO YEARS
AND WE HAD A VERY ROBUST
ARGUMENT ABOUT THIS.
IN THE BUDGET CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE THE
LEGISLATURE DESIRE TO MAKE THIS
EXEMPTION PERMANENT THE
ADMINISTRATION INSISTED THAT
THAT ARE ONLY BE FOR TWO YEARS
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IN
SYSTEMS.
SO THAT THEY COULD LABEL IT A
ONE TIME EXPENDITURE REVENUE
INSTEAD OF AN ONGOING
EXPENDITURE REVENUE NOW I FEEL
STRONGLY THAT THAT IS JUST
KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD IS
ASKING.
FUTURE VERSIONS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE TO DEAL WITH THIS
PROBLEM AGAIN AND AGAIN AND WE
SHOULD JUST REMOVE THAT
EXEMPTION TO DO THIS --
PERMANENTLY HOWEVER FOR NOW I
REGION I VOTE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF
RESERVE OF ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE ABOUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE TIE THAT I
SEVENTY TWO NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES IN
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE MEDIA TO
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE THE FILE THIS
IS SB.
NINETY THREE SENATE BILL NINETY
THREE BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY
THE STATE BUDGET MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BILL.
MISTER KING.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB
NINETY THREE AMENDS THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET TO ADDRESS
UNANTICIPATED EXPENSES THAT
OCCURRED IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
THE BILL ADDRESSES A HUNDRED AND
TWELVE POINT SIX MILLION AND
ARTISTS ABATED DEFICIENCIES.
A MUCH SMALLER AMOUNT THAN WHAT
IS USUALLY DONE ALMOST ALL THESE
COSTS ARE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
OVERTURES FROM HAVING TO
MAINTAIN OUT OF STATE.
CONTRACT THAT'S LONGER THAN
EXPECTED AND FROM NEW COSTS FOR
PRACTICE REQUESTED FROM THE
FEDERAL HEALTH RECEIVER WHO'S
OVERSEEING THE DEPARTMENT --
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE ON SB.
NINETY THREE NAME IS JANE MISTER
OVER NOTHING MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
THREE THIS BILL APPROPRIATES.
MONEY FOR CONTINGENCIES AND
EMERGENCIES THOSE APPROPRIATIONS
ARE SUPPORTABLE ARJUN AYE VOTE.
WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
IS SB.
NINETY FOUR SB NINETY FOUR
CORKERY SAMPLE NINETY FOUR BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC SAFETY MAKING PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET.
MR TANG.
I THINK IT WAS SPEAKER SB NINETY
FOUR INCLUDES VARIOUS TECHNICAL
IN SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES NECESSARY
TO IMPLEMENT PUBLIC SAFETY
PRIORITIES IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET.
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO REPORT ANNUALLY ON
THE ARM PROHIBITED PERSON SYSTEM.
IN THE COMMISSION ON PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
TO REPORT ON TRAININGS PROVIDED
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT ALO MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION INCLUDING THE
TRANSFER OF THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE FROM CDC ARE.
TO THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY.
THE TRAILER BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES THE COMMITTEE ON
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE.
THEY ALSO SELL MUCH OF THE
CALIFORNIA RE ENTRY INTO
RICHMOND GRANT PROGRAM.
PROVIDE GRANTS TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES IN
PERSON.
AND ALSO ON THE FINALLY THE BILL
INCREASES THE PAROLE HEARING
COMMISSIONS BY TWO FOR A TOTAL
OF SEVENTEEN COMMISSIONERS.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THEY WISH TING MEASURE OF
ARNOLDI MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION SB NINETY FOUR THIS
TRAILER BILL WOULD MOVE THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THIS IS AN EXTREMELY
INAPPROPRIATE CHANGE.
THE DJJ CURRENTLY HOUSES SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY YOUTHFUL
OFFENDERS WHO HAVE ALL COMMITTED
THE MOST SERIOUS FELONY OFFENSES
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR CRIMINAL
CODE I'M TALKING ABOUT THINGS.
LIKE MURDER IN VERY SERIOUS SEX
CRIMES TO MOVE THAT DIVISION TO
A DEPARTMENT THAT HAS NO
EXPERIENCE IN CORRECTIONAL
OVERSIGHT WOULD BE NOT ONLY
UNNECESSARY BUT ALSO ON WISE I
REGIONAL VOTE.
I SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCLOSURE
DEBATE ON THE ITEM [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF THESE ARE ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I FIFTY
FOUR NO.
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
IS SB NINETY FIVE CORPORATION.
SENATE BILL NINETY FIVE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE COURTS
MAKE IN PREPARATION THEREFORE TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER TECH.
THANK YOU SB NINETY FIVES ARE
COURTS TRAILER BILL ESTABLISHES
TWENTY FIVE ADDITIONAL
JUDGESHIPS.
IT ALSO INCREASES THE TRIAL
COURT'S RESERVE AMOUNTS FROM 1%
23% ENHANCING BUDGET STABILITY --
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THEY WISHING MISTER OVERALL TO
ARISE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
FIVE THE TWENTY FIVE ADDITIONAL
JUDGESHIPS THAT APPROPRIATE IN
THIS BILL ARE BADLY NEEDED IN
CALIFORNIA AND TO PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE.
THE THE IS CURRENTLY ESTIMATED
THAT WE ARE SHORT ABOUT A
HUNDRED EIGHTY JUDGES IN
CALIFORNIA SO TWENTY FIVE IS A
GOOD START.
ALSO THE REMOVAL OF THAT 1% CAP
IN THE IMPOSITION OF A 3% CAP ON
JUDICIAL RESERVES WILL HELP
COURTS PLAN FOR THEIR FINANCIAL
FUTURE ALTHOUGH.
THE CASE COULD BE MADE THAT
REALLY THERE SHOULDN'T BE A CAP
ON THOSE RESERVES NEVERTHELESS
THIS MOVE THE BALL IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND I REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OF NINETY SEEN
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE [inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS.
WHO IS OUR VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THOUGH?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SEVENTY
THREE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE.
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
IS SB NINETY SIX THE CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL NINETY SIX BUT THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY TAXATION
CLEARING THE URGENCY THERE UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
[inaudible]
YOUR TECH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB
NINETY SIX IS PERTAINING TO OUR
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM -- IF WE
HAVEN'T FOUND THE NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM TO BE IMPORTANT -- BEFORE
IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS GIVEN
THE NUMBER OF DISASTERS WE'VE
HAD.
UP AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE SYSTEM IS
ACTUALLY CRITICAL TO MAKE SURE
THAT FIRST RESPONDERS CAN GET TO
OUR COMMUNITIES AS FAST AS
HUMANLY POSSIBLE.
SO BEGINNING IN JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY THIS BILL AMENDS
THE STATE EMERGENCY TELEPHONE
USERS SURCHARGE ACT WHICH
IMPOSES A MONTHLY SURCHARGE
AMOUNT OF NOT GREATER THAN
EIGHTY CENTS NOT GREATER THAN
EIGHTY CENTS.
PER ACCESS LINE TO FUND THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEARS NINE ONE
ONE COSTS.
ON OR AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THE BILL WOULD IMPOSE A
SURCHARGE FOR PREPAID MOBILE
TELEPHONE SERVICES AT THE TIME
OF EACH RETAIL TRANSACTION IN
THE STATE.
AT THE RATE EQUAL TO THE MONTHLY
SURCHARGE AMOUNT PER ACCESS LINE
TO BE PAID BY THE PREPAID CUSTOM
CONSUMERS.
AND COLLECTORS OF SELLERS.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE
SURCHARGE BE REMITTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND
FEE ADMINISTRATION.
THE BILL ALLOWS NEXT GENERATION
NINE ONE ONE IN THE SUBSEQUENT
TECHNOLOGIES INTERFACES NEED TO
DELIVER. NINE ONE ONE VOICE AND
DATA INFORMATION WITHIN THE
MEANING OF BASIC SYSTEM FOR THE
PURPOSES OF STATE EMERGENCY
NUMBER ACCOUNT EXPENDITURES.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE FOR SB.
NINETY SIX MR OF ANALYTICS
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINETY SIX THIS
BILL WILL IMPOSE A SURCHARGE OF
UP TO EIGHTY CENTS PER LINE ON
EVERY PHONE LINE AND CELL PHONE
IN CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD HOPE WE COULD ALL AGREE
THAT FUNDING NEXT GENERATION
NINE ONE ONE SHOULD BE A STATE
PRIORITY HOWEVER KEEP IN MIND
THAT WE'RE DOING THIS IN A YEAR
WHEN WE HAVE A TWENTY ONE
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET SURPLUS.
WE COULD EASILY FUND THIS
PROGRAM FROM THE GENERAL FUND
INSTEAD OF ASKING CALIFORNIANS
TO PAY MORE MANY OF WHOM ARE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR
BILLS EVERY DAY.
I ALSO LIKE YOU COULD CONSIDER
THIS EVEN IF YOU FEEL LIKE A PER
MONTH PER LINE SURCHARGES THE
APPROPRIATE WAY TO FUND THIS
PROGRAM.
WHY ARE WE BEING ASKED TO
AUTHORIZE UP TO EIGHTY CENTS PER
LINE WHEN THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES ITSELF SAYS
THAT ONLY THIRTY FOUR CENTS PER
LINE IS REQUIRED TO FULLY FUND
THE PROGRAM RIGHT NOW?
I WOULD ASK YOU TO IF YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO VOTE NO AT LEAST OF
STAYING UNTIL WE CAN STEP AT
MAXIMUM CAP DOWN TO AROUND FORTY
CENTS PER LINE WHICH WOULD BE A
MUCH MORE APPROPRIATE LEVEL.
I URGE A NO VOTE.
MISS SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS TRAILER BILL IN THIS
MEASURE IS SUSTAINABILITY OF OUR
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM WHICH IS A
PUBLIC GOOD.
I WOULD HAZARD A GUESS THAT MOST
OF US IN THIS ROOM AT SOME POINT
IN OUR LIVES HAVE PICKED UP THE
PHONE TO DIAL.
911- WHETHER WE WERE SEEING A
FIRE HAD A LOVED ONE IN DISTRESS
HAD SOME OTHER NEED THAT
REQUIRED FIRST RESPONDERS TO
COME TO OUR AID IMMEDIATELY.
YES WE HAVE A SURPLUS BUT WE
DON'T ALWAYS HAVE A SURPLUS IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE WILL ALWAYS HAVE
EMERGENCIES GIVEN THE NATURE OF
HOW WE ALL COMMUNICATE AND HOW
WE PAY FOR THOSE COMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS.
WE NEED TO PUT THIS MEASURE IN
PLACE TO ENSURE SUSTAINABILITY
OF A SYSTEM WE ALL COUNT ON OUR
CONSTITUENTS ALL COUNT ON EVERY
DAY AND IN PERPETUITY SO I CAN
REALLY REALLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
EYES.
FIFTY FIVE KNOWS ELEVEN ON THE
URGENCY EYES FIFTY FIVE KNOWS
ELEVEN ON THE MEASURE.
THAT TRAILER BILL PASSES AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL. TO THE SENATE
.
MEMBERS BACK ON THE THIRD
READING FILE.
GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
TEN WE'VE ALREADY DISPENSED WITH
FILE ITEM FILE ITEMS NUMBER
ELEVEN AND TWELVE WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN THIS IS A
C. R. ONE L. THREE FIVE IS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
CARILLO.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE OH THREE BY SOMETHING NUMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO LATEX ALLERGY AWARENESS WEEK.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
A C. R. ONE OH THREE WHICH FOUR
PROCLAIMS OCTOBER.
SIX TO TWELVE OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AS LATEX ALLERGY
AWARENESS WEEK.
LATEX ALLERGY IS CAUSED BY
EXPOSURE TO NATURAL RUBBER LATEX
IT IS PROGRESSIVE AND IT HAS NO
CURE.
THE ONLY TREATMENT FOR LATEX
ALLERGY IS TO AVOID LATEX WHICH
IS INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT BECAUSE
LATEX IS IN. FORTY THOUSAND
DIFFERENT CONSUMER PRODUCTS LIKE
BALLOONS OFFICE SUPPLIES AND
MEDICAL GLOVES.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW HOW SERIOUS A
LATEX ALLERGY COULD BE.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE TO GO ON
DISABILITY A SERIOUS ALLERGIC
REACTION CAN BE TRIGGERED BY
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS TOUCHING
A RUBBER BAND.
IT IS A DAILY STRUGGLE FOR THOSE
WITH LATEX ALLERGIES TO BALANCE
LIFE AND WORK.
WITH STAYING SAFE AND HEALTHY.
ACR A ONE OH THREE WILL INCREASE
AWARENESS AND EDUCATIONAL
EFFORTS ON LATEX ALLERGIES AND
WILL ENCOURAGE ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO BE INFORMED ABOUT THE CAUSES.
SYMPTOMS AND PREVENTION OF LATEX
ALLERGY REACTIONS.
I'D LIKE TO OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
AYE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SEEN
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
RESOLUTION THE AUTHORS ASKING
THE FOR SHALL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON ACR ONE OH THREE THIS IS CO
AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
EIGHT CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE.
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED [inaudible]
MISTER CALDERON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER SB TWO NINETY DON.
FROM THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE TO THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE AND THEN
BACK TO THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I WAS BACK ON THE THIRD READING
FILE FILE ITEMS FOURTEEN THROUGH
TWENTY ONE ON THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE PASS
AND RETAIN
.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE
GOING TO BE TAKING UP.
ON THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTEEN WHICH IS SB SIX THIRTY
ON SENATE THIRD READING
CORPORATION.
SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY BY
SENATOR STERN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
MR SANTIAGO.
I THINK IT WAS A SPEAKER AB SIX
THIRTY WOULD GIVE LOCAL THE
AUTHORITY TO ENACT ORDINANCES TO
ENFORCE POSTING NOTICES ABOUT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
ESPECIALLY NATIONAL VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE.
DESERVE THAT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL AND TELL YOU ABOUT I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
AND NOW WE'LL MOVE TO VOTE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
IS ANY MEMBER WE SHOULD MOVE
ADAM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
EGG THANK CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY TRY RESOLUTION FIFTEEN
BY SOME IMPROVE THEM RELATIVE TO
SECTION TO GO TO SUPPORT OF
HOUSING FOR THE ELDERLY PROGRAM.
CLUB IN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEM ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY
FOUR I SEVENTY FOUR NO.
ZERO MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY JUNE EIGHTEENTH TRACK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY JUNE
NINETEENTH CHECK IN SESSION.
AND THURSDAY JUNE TWENTIETH
FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE AM
.
MISTER CALDERON FOR WHAT PURPOSE
THE RIDES.
I SB -- NINETY SIX NOVO CHANGES
AROUND.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE
.
MEMBERS OF THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED GERMANS IN
MEMORY.
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.
SORRY THE QUORUM CALL IS NOT
LIFTED THE QUORUM CALL IS NOT
[inaudible]
LIFTED MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
FOR GERMAN TO MEMORY PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION YOUR
COLLEAGUES.
FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARENA PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR.
AGAIN A QUORUM CALL IS NOT
LIFTED [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF REVEREND
JAMES V. MATTHEWS THE SECOND WHO
PASSED AWAY ON MARCH THIRTIETH.
TWENTY NINETEEN FATHER J. AS
GENERATIONS OF OAKLAND IS CALLED
HIM WAS SEVENTY YEARS OLD.
FATHER J. WITH THE SON OF THE
EAST BAY BORN IN BERKELEY.
AND RAISED IN OAKLAND.
WHEN FATHER JAY WAS A YOUNG
TEENAGER OAKLAND'S FIRST BISHOP
FLOYD BEGIN SUGGESTED AT HIS
CONFIRMATION THAT HE?
BECOME A PRIEST.
HE WENT ON TO DO JUST THAT.
FATHER J. GRADUATED FROM SKYLINE
HIGH SCHOOL IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SIX RECEIVED A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
IN HUMANITIES AND PHILOSOPHY
FROM SAINT PATRICK'S COLLEGE
MOUNTAIN VIEW IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY AND EARNED A
MASTER'S DEGREE FROM SAINT
PATRICK'S SEMINARY MENLO PARK IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE A YEAR
LATER IN MAY NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR HE WAS ORDAINED BECOMING
THE FIRST.
AFRICAN AMERICAN TO BE ORDAINED
AS A PRIEST IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
FATHER J. SERVE THE OAKLAND
COMMUNITY FOR THE NEXT FOUR
DECADES INCLUDING.
IN ST BENEDICT'S CHURCH IN
OAKLAND ST CORNELIUS CHURCH IN
RICHMOND ST ZERO CHURCH IN
OAKLAND ALL SAINTS CHURCH IN
HAYWARD.
ST LOUIS BURKE TRENCHARD IN
OAKLAND AND ST ANTHONY CHURCH.
IN OAKLAND IF THAT WEREN'T
ENOUGH FATHER J. ALSO SERVED AS
THE VICAR FOR BLACK CATHOLICS A
CHAPLAIN FOR THE OAKLAND POLICE
AND FIRE DEPARTMENTS.
AND A TEACHER AT BISHOP O'DOWD.
HIGH SCHOOL.
FATHER JAY'S IMPACT ON THE EAST
BAY COMMUNITY AND BEYOND.
WAS BEYOND MEASURE SO DEEP AND
MEANINGFUL THAT THE CITY OF
OAKLAND DESIGNATED A FATHER JAY
MATHEWS DAY IN.
NINETEEN NINETY ONE AGAIN IN.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE AND YET
AGAIN IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN FATHER J. WAS
FRIENDLY AND WARM THOUGHTFUL.
AND ENGAGING HE WAS QUICK TO
LAUGH AND SMILE AND WAS NEVER
BASHFUL ABOUT PUTTING HIS BIG
HEART.
ON FULL DISPLAY.
HE WAS ALWAYS CONSPIRING TO MAKE
OUR COMMUNITY BETTER. TO ELECTED
OFFICIALS HE WAS WELL KNOWN FOR
HIS GENEROSITY IN GIVING US FREE
ADVICE.
FATHER J. WAS A LOT OF THINGS TO
A LOT OF PEOPLE. TO ME HE WAS A
MORAL COMPASS A WISE COUNSEL
SOMEONE WHO SPOKE WITH A MORAL
AUTHORITY THAT I TRUSTED AND
LISTENED CLOSELY.
TO HE CHALLENGED ME AND MADE ME
BETTER AND HE WOULD HE WOULD
INVITE ME IN AND SAY.
LET'S MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
STRONGER TOGETHER.
FATHER J. MATTHEWS EXEMPLIFY
SERVICED ONCE COMMUNITY SERVICE
THAT IS ROOTED IN LOVE.
COMPASSION [inaudible]
HUMANITY GENEROSITY FAITH ENJOY.
FATHER JAY AND HIS LEGACY OF
TIRELESS UNCEASING SERVICE IS
CERTAINLY A PART OF OUR HISTORY
AS OAKLAND HERS.
AND AS CALIFORNIANS THAT WE WILL
NOT SOON FORGET.
I ASKED AT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED TODAY.
AND THE MEMORY OF FATHER J.
MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA DOCTOR
WEBER YOU WERE ALSO RECOGNIZE ON
THIS GERMAN MEMORY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS.
IN REQUESTED WE JOIN IN MEMORY
OF ON BEHALF OF FATHER J.
MATTHEWS -- EST AS STATED WE
KNOW WHERE HE WAS BORN A AND AND
WHERE HE DID HIS WORK WAS IN THE
BAY AREA -- HE WAS KNOWN AS
FATHER J. TOO MANY MANY ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND MEMBERS OF THE
OAKLAND COMMUNITY.
HE DREW HIS DEEP CONVICTION AND
COMMITMENT TO COMMUNITIES AT TO
PROVIDE PASTORAL SERVICE IN
PARTNERSHIP TO CIVIC AND WELLS
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS.
HE TRULY WAS A FIXTURE OF THE
WAS ALSO A FIXTURE OF THE PUBLIC
AND SOCIAL COMMUNITY AS WELL.
HE IMP HE IMPACTED THE LIVES OF
MOST OF THE AFRICAN AMERICANS
WHO SERVED IN ELECTED OFFICIALS
IN THE BAY AREA.
HE WAS KNOWN AS THE LIGHT OF THE
COMMUNITY WHO LIVE THE LIFE OF
SERVICE FOR EVERYONE AROUND HIM.
AND HE WILL SURELY BE MISSED OUR
PRAYERS ARE WITH HIM AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS WE GIVE
OUR PRAYERS TO HIS FAMILY.
AND TO THE ENTIRE CONGREGATION
AND WE ASK THAT WE JOINED IN
MEMORY OF FATHER JAY MATHEWS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WHOEVER.
IS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR TERM MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF MY DEAR FRIEND MENTOR
AND CONSTITUENTS.
MISTER JACK BE WHITE OF BALDWIN
PARK.
JACK WAS BORN IN OKLAHOMA ON
JULY THIRD.
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE ON MAY
TWENTY THIRD TWENTY NINETEEN HE
PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY AT THE
AGE OF EIGHTY FIVE IN HIS HOME
INVOLVED IN PARK.
AFTER HARD FOUGHT HARD FOUGHT
BATTLE AGAINST CANCER AND
PARKINSON'S DISEASE.
JACK ENLISTED IN THE ARMY AT AGE
SEVENTEEN I BECAME A PROUD
MEMBER OF THE EIGHTY SECOND
AIRBORNE DIVISION AIRBORNE
DIVISION.
HE LEFT THE ARMY AS SERGEANT
FIRST CLASS AND A FEW YEARS
LATER JOINED THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
DURING HIS TIME AT LAPD HEARING
HIS BA AT CAL STATE LA.
HE MOVED THROUGH THE RANKS OF
THE LAPD AND RETIRED AT THE RANK
OF COMMANDER.
UPON RETIREMENT FROM THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT HE BECAME CHIEF OF
THE BUREAU OF INVESTIGATIONS FOR
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
WHILE PURSUING HIS LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAREER.
JACK CONTINUED HIS PERSONAL AND
PROFESSIONAL GROWTH BY BURNING
THE A BA IT BE A DEGREE IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE FROM CAL STATE
LA.
AND COMPLETING GRADUATE WORK IN
BOTH WE'LL LET MATTER MERRIMENT
UNIVERSITY AND UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AS A LONG TIME BOTTOM PARK
RESIDENT JACK DEDICATED
SIGNIFICANT TIME.
ENERGY AND RESOURCES TO HIS
COMMUNITY GENEROUSLY SHARING HIS
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS AS A LITTLE
LEAGUE COACH AN ELECTED MEMBER
OF THE BOTTOM PART CITY COUNCIL.
JACK DISTINGUISHED HIMSELF AS A
CAPABLE AND EFFECTIVE LEADER.
DURING HIS TIME.
AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL HE SERVED
AS MAYOR FOR BALDWIN PARK FOR
TEN YEARS AND SERVED ON THE
BOTTOM PARK UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS.
JACK CHAMPION THE EXPANSION OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
INVOLVED IN PARK AND PLAYED A
LARGE ROLE IN THE CONSTRUCTION
OF A THREE STORY SCIENCE AND
ENGINEERING BUILDING.
MODERN ATHLETIC STADIUMS AND
FIELD THAT TO DISTRICT HIGH
SCHOOLS.%
HE WAS HONORED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WITH THE NAMING OF THE
JACK BE WHITE STADIUM AT SERVICE
TO HIGH SCHOOL INVOLVED IN PARK.
HE DEFINITELY WAS A CHAMPION FOR
HIS COMMUNITY. FOR ME.
HE WAS A FRIEND A MENTOR AND A
FATHER FIGURE FOR BOTH MYSELF
AND MY SISTER SENATOR SUSAN
RUBIO.
HE LOVED AND ENCOURAGED ME
THROUGH EVERY STEP OF MY
POLITICAL CAREER.
JACK KNEW WHAT I WAS CAPABLE OF
ACCOMPLISHING EVEN BEFORE I KNEW.
I CAN HONESTLY TELL YOU THAT
SENATOR RUBIO AND I WOULD NOT BE
HERE.
WOULD NOT BE FOR JACK THE WHITE.
FOR OVER TWENTY TWO YEARS JACK
AND I SPOKE AT LEAST ONCE A WEEK.
WE DISCUSSED LIFE AND POLITICS
HE TOLD ME STORIES ABOUT HIS
LIFE THAT TAUGHT ME THE
IMPORTANCE OF GIVING MORE THAN
WHAT WE RECEIVED.
IN MY HOUSE HE'S REFERS TO
REFERRED TO AS UNCLE JACK.
AND HIS WIFE OF SIXTY FIVE YEARS
AT THE WHITE HOUSE GRABBED MY AT
NAM.
I WANT TO THANK GRABBED MY AND
NOT GRAN MY AND NOT.
THEIR CHILDREN JACQUI STAN AND
ANGIE FOR LETTING ME PART OF BE
PART OF THEIR FAMILY.
ENSURING JACK WITH ME AND MY
FAMILY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE HAD
DURING THE MEMORY OF AN AMAZING
MAN.
JACK BE WHITE.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN A
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF
AMANDA HAVE A GREAT DEAL RESPECT.
FOR RON NICHOLS PRESIDENT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON.
RON SPENT THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF
HIS LIFE IN THE ENERGY SECTOR.
HE WAS A TIRELESS CHAMPION NOT
ONLY AN S. C. E..
BUT THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THE
COUNTRY. FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
CLEAN ENERGY PARTICULARLY FOR
PROGRAMS THAT BENEFIT CUSTOMERS
AN ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT TO
COMMUNITIES.
FITTINGLY JUST LAST WEEK.
EDISON WAS MADE AWARE THAT RON
WAS RECOGNIZE WITH THE SMART
ELECTRIC POWER ALLIANCE POWER
PLAYER OF THE YEAR. ONE OF THE
MOST PRESTIGIOUS AWARDS IN THE
INDUSTRY FOR THE INVESTMENT OF
CLEAN ENERGY INITIATIVES.
I'M HAPPY TO SAY WRONG LEARNED
OF THIS GREAT HONOR BEFORE HIS
PASSING.
BEFORE JOINING SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN RUN SEARCH FOR
THREE YEARS AS GENERAL MANAGER
OF LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF
WATER AND POWER.
THERE HE PROVIDED LEADERSHIP FOR
THE UTILITY AND SUPPLYING
RELIABILITY AND COMPETITIVELY
PRICED WATER AND ELECTRICITY
WHILE KEEPING ENVIRONMENT.
TOP OF HIS MIND.
HIS COMMITMENT TO CUSTOMERS IS
COMMUNITY HIS COLLEAGUES IN HIS
FAMILY WAS EVIDENCED BY HOW HE
TREATED THEM WITH KINDNESS AND
RESPECT.
RHONDA SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
CHERYL AND THEIR FAMILIES.
HE WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR GERMAN IN
HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES OF THE
DESK TO PRINT IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST RETURNING MEMORY WILL BE
DEEMED READ.
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
OF THE ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING OF FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
MOTION OR GERMS TO CALL THEIR
OWN MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY JUNE
TWENTY EIGHTH AT NINE AM IN THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED
.
MODE CHANGE LACKEY SAID ABILITY
TO ITEM NO.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY SENATE BILL EIGHTY TWO I
TO KNOW